hello everyone um shinyan
happy new year everyone
my name is scout chao and i am a
veterinarian specializing in laboratory
animal medicine i currently work
in china for a company called ushi ap
tech in suzhou
um
and as we are in the business of
performing contract research
uh one of my responsibilities is to
ensure that the animal models that we
use are indeed suitable
for research purpose and so
um
one of the ways i accomplish this task
is by performing regular vendor audit
assessment
regular vendor assessments
and today i will share some of my
experiences with you related to this
topic and hopefully through this
presentation entices you to want to pay
your own vendors a visit
and before i begin i just want to
mention that some of the photos that are
shown in this presentation either came
from my photo collection
they were downloaded from the internet
or solicited from my colleagues from
around the world so these pictures are
really meant to illustrate a point
rather than
serving as an endorsement from myself or
for my company for any products or
services
so
and of course during the presentation
please feel free to
enter your questions
or comments using your little uh click
box here
and you may type in english or if you
like in mandarin i will try to answer
your your questions at the end of the
session
all right
and here we go
so the objectives of my presentation
today is really to first
review some of the reasons why it is
important to assess animal and supply
vendors used in biomedical research
today
and um
and and certainly
our goal is to control factors that
could potentially compound your animal
research and the data
but also for the purpose of quality
assurance
from an animal welfare assurance
perspective we want to be doing this
um
secondly i want to go over some of the
approaches that i've taken
for performing vendor assessments and
with the focus primarily on the animal
vendors and um and diet vendors but
certainly other vendors such as your
bedding um you know enrichment toys some
of those
the same principle will apply um and at
the end i really just want to stress
this point that you know the the reason
we're doing this is because we want to
build a strong partnership with our
vendors you know in this journey that we
we are making contributions towards
scientific advancement so it's important
that you pick
um a
you know companies that work
synergistically with you
rather than than against you
now
we understand that animal research
involves a collection of data from
carefully designed experiments
and good research is really built on
foundations of sound methods and
appropriate animal models
so in order to maintain research
integrity
it's important to be aware and try to
control as many of these factors
that of course can influence your your
research data
next for animal assurance welfare
assurance
you can imagine you know caring for
animals that you cannot use
is really a waste of animals a waste of
time and waste of resources
we don't certainly we don't want to
unnecessarily euthanize animals
we don't want to cause delays to studies
we don't want to accidentally bring
diseases and petulances into our
facilities
and all of these of course can have
significant impact
on
your animal population and on your
operation overall
and so think about everything that your
animals could potentially come in
contact with you know the like i said
the the
feed water bedding toys um anything that
potentially they could ingest you know
are these things are these products safe
uh
does it does it impact your your data in
in one way or another so think about
those factors
and um
and really for your peers to trust the
data and the conclusions that you make
from your study and for the sake of you
know future scientists that are coming
up behind you wanting to replicate your
study it is imperative that you are
aware of both human factors and animal
factors that can impact your data right
human factors of course
we're talking about how
people conduct studies but the animal
factors themselves if you think about it
not only do animals intrinsically have
uh factors that impact steady outcome
but also what is around
the environment the extrinsic factors
okay
and so a little bit more specifically
intrinsic factors when i talk about
these we're talking about animals
genetics their background their age
their
sex their immune status their
nutritional status
things like circadian rhythms their
endocrine factors
these last two points
are somewhat tied to the extrinsic
factors as well
and by extrinsic we're thinking about
the animal's environment
the
the food that they eat the cajun system
that they're held in
the water that they drink
chemical factors like i mentioned oh i'm
sorry the environmentals uh we're
thinking about
temperature humidity the light cycles
things that our our facilities try to
control uh the chemical factors then is
that the food the diet the diet the
water uh the toys anything that
you prescribe as a as a treatment or you
um
put into
the test system you know because of your
experiments so these chemical factors
can impact your study outcome
uh certainly the microbial status of the
animals uh you know the the set of of
these microorganisms that they come with
and also what's in your environment that
could potentially be added into onto
your animals
and finally the the stressors
um you know as a result of male
adaptation to either human manipulation
or to some other
factors in the environment so all of
this you know it's a combination of all
these factors that determines your your
research outcome and then how you
interpret your data then you know really
depends on whether or not you take these
factors into consideration
okay
um so going into reasons for assessing
vendors
hopefully
you know you think about all the things
that we currently do to try to control
our animals within
our facility
now do you ever think about where your
animals come from or where your diets
come from you know how they were made
okay
um
certainly we think about this as one of
the responsibilities of the veterinarian
because you know we're responsible for
overseeing the animal procurement
process to make sure they are suitable
for research
and i certainly consider
vendor assessment being one of these
responsibilities
internally based on your institutional
requirements there may be uh
you know
certain standards that you need to meet
so internal compliance as required that
tells you you need to go out and assess
vendors qualify them before
you allow
you are allowed to bring in the animals
or the products into your facility to be
used on studies
um
and certainly you do want to make sure
that whatever it is that you bring in
and are used on studies
these products and services they
actually meet your study needs
okay you have to think about that
um and again i talked about building
this trust between you and your vendors
you know yes you're buying their product
at hopefully a good price but do you
trust
what they provide with for you is is
what you're expecting okay so that trust
component is very important
all right
so i'm using this as an example um in
you know you you receive this white
fluffy rabbit you know in your in your
doorstep and you know it's accompanied
by a health certificate that says clean
grave rabbit you know
and
did you know that it is possible to have
this health designation the clean gray
rabbit you know if the animal is bred in
one of these four facilities you know
the one in the top upper corner hold on
you see
um
yeah so
here
i'm not going to use this all right
the point is that in in any one of these
facilities it is possible for the
animals to come out and and be
accompanied by a health certificate that
says this animal needs clean grade
health status
okay and secondly what you want to think
about is after you receive this animal
you know it's white it's fluffy
it looks like a rabbit but in asia there
are several vendors that actually breed
and produce japanese japanese whites
and so
um this uh breed distinction
depending on your study it may matter or
may not okay
so
these are some of the things that
hopefully you're starting to think about
as you look at your animals
and before you use them
um
and
for me as a
veterinarian and as manager of vivarium
this is probably one of the points i
always try to emphasize as a reason for
visiting your vendor
without going too much into details all
i want to mention is that within china
regulatory agencies have said microbial
testing standards for commonly used
laboratory animal species and they have
established different classes of
laboratory animals based on based on
their health profile
um so for example conventional clean spf
and a zenic okay and for those of us
trained and have worked in um in the
west and in other parts of the world i
just want to remind you that you know
some of these terminologies don't assume
when it's used it is the same as what
you think you knew okay
so don't assume that an spf animal that
you get domestically is the of the same
health profile as an spf animal you get
from abroad okay
look specifically
at the agents that have been tested you
know look at the report look at the
detail report okay and pay attention to
not what's only tested but also think
about what agents are not tested for
okay and then think about whether or not
uh these missing information how that is
going to impact your operation
okay
um and so going back to the example of
having clean grade rabbits
um based on the
gb standard in china a clean gray rabbit
are
required to be
free of these following agents listed on
the left
up the slide here
a couple of iron
here one virus a couple of bacteria
fungi
actually no no fungus on there
and tested for parasites and this is
done every three months
and this in comparison to the philosophy
recommended guidelines listed on the
right here in the table
it is missing a couple of agents okay
and as compared to some of the vendors
that i know from north america my
experience in north america it is
missing a few more and so
um think about the potential impact this
may have on your research and um you
know make an educated decision
okay
all right
so with that hopefully
i have given you enough reasons to think
about
maybe i should be involved in the vendor
assessment um process
all right
and if you're just starting out
think about all the stakeholders who are
um who should be involved
in
performing vendor assessments okay is it
the veterinarians your animal welfare
specialist your operation managers
perhaps
the the scientists who are using the
animals some of the funding agencies you
know what about others
um i i don't support some institutions
that rely or that place uh this
responsibility on folks doing purchasing
because they are non-science people and
they're really not in the best people to
be able to make this decision for you
you know for science so
think about the key people you want
involved in this process
and when you go and perform vendor
assessments you could be qualifying
vendors
by doing audits or
you could be going there to perform
animal welfare audits okay
these are
two separate components sometimes are
done at the same time
when you qualify a vendor you're
basically going there to assess the
product quality and make sure that the
vendor is able to meet your demands and
the quality with the quality of the
products they sell
meets your expectation you know that's
pretty much it and that their paperwork
to to back up their practice uh but the
animal welfare audits involve a little
bit more um because you want to go there
and assess whether or not
the animals are being treated humanely
that the animals look healthy content
uh free from pain and diseases and um
and that the overall operation
complies with international standards
for animal care
you may assess vendors
by
uh by sending out questionnaires
or
or and or you can perform on-site visits
okay
um the questionnaires are useful when in
the beginning you're trying to screen
vendors to to select you know try to
narrow down uh to a couple of vendors
that you want to use so think of it like
shopping for a car you want to you do
want to shop around and check out
different dealers to to see who has the
best product that meets your your
expectations
okay
and this questionnaires you send out
typically contain or you ask for
information such as
company contact uh what is their
organization structure
ask them to give a description of their
products and services you know brief
overview what is the size of their
operation what are their capabilities
okay
um do they need regulatory compliance
you know or do they have accreditation
status
um
some of this basic information their
staff you know how how many staff work
for them what is their training program
like
um you may even ask them to provide
brief description for the animal care
and veterinary care practice if this is
animal vendors you're talking about
um and then you might want to ask
them to provide a little bit information
about their internal quality control
system their program to ensure you know
consistency in their model or their
product production
and certainly you don't want to make
this questionnaire so cumbersome that it
takes a long time for the vendor to
to fill out and to return to you
at the same time you want to use this
tool um to to weed out
um suppliers out there who you know if
you know for example if they can even
fill out these simple questions then
most likely they're not going to meet
your demands and then you know there's
no need to really make a trip out there
to pay them a visit so
use this as a pre-screening process
and
you know you
you do want to give the vendors ample
time to answer these questions and so
typically i send these out about two to
four weeks in advance and then i set a
return by date so that
it's not just flowing out there so
you want to you want to give yourself a
chance to follow through
um and as you prepare for your audit or
your visit
uh think about what your study needs are
you know based on your your researcher
based on the type of uh studies that you
you um perform in in your organization
uh what is the the animal species uh
rodent strain or stock that you need the
age of the animals this the sex of the
animals uh do you work with special
disease models um
some of these mutant models you know how
how many do you need at one time how
often you know whether or not
uh the vendor will be able to meet your
expectations will depend on all of these
um and also think about some of the
alternatives you know like i was saying
before um like shopping for a car you
don't just go to one vendor and you buy
a car one dealer and buy your car you
you also try to
not limit yourself to just one vendor
right you always want to have a backup
just in case something were to happen
you know the first vendor is unable to
meet your your supply needs
um
you know research these vendors ahead of
time a lot of them have websites you
know just go on there check it out and
see how their websites look and
sometimes that gives you an idea of how
professional
this this
company is
to help you
maintain your consistency in your audit
process uh definitely develop a standard
list of questions for yourself to follow
okay
and
things like
standard list of documents that you want
to to review when you visit and if you
want you can forward this to the vendor
ahead of time just so they can start
pulling the documents together and
prepare
okay
um and certainly you want to ask about
restrictions uh some of their policies
internal policies related to your visits
for example when you're going to visit a
non-human primary breeding facility most
often or almost always you're going to
have to bring a proof of tb negative
status with you okay but some vendors
will have requirements that this this
proof needs to be within three months or
six months or for a year um so you just
want to make sure that whatever
documents that you bring um meets uh
meets
their
expectations
some vendors may ask that you don't come
in contact with other animals before
arriving at their facility and so if
you're on a vendor audit trip and you
plan to go to different places then you
might want to adjust your travel
itinerary and your schedule accordingly
um you know i've been to even one
facility where the host asked you to
take away wet shower before going into
their facility and so you know just want
to find out the details before you show
up to avoid getting stuck in these
awkward situations okay
um the typical checklist items that i
asked for
here they are i usually ask for evidence
of regulatory compliance so ask them to
show copies of
operating permits
um if they get inspected from local
regulatory agencies asked to see a copy
of the report
if they are
a-lac accredited facility ask to see the
program description
okay
um things like that
organization chart you know by looking
at that you can get a sense of whether
or not the operating unit gets
sufficient support from the management
units
okay
um ask for a list of sops and related
documents you know because you want to
make sure that they are
you know
producing you know following a set of
guidelines
okay so ask for the index and
depending on what you feel like um you
can focus in on
certain key areas and ask to see those
specific sops or you can make that
decision after you
go on tour and based on what you see um
you know any red flag areas then you can
pull those sops and read up on it
um ask to see employee training records
i typically ask for somebody you know
new on coming into to uh
someone new starting to work there uh
somebody who was experienced
i was sometimes asked to see you know
the training records for their attending
veterinarians
uh
and um
and and you can see whether or not the
company invests in
the the education the training um
and the safety of their employees
through these training records
um you can ask whether or not they have
an aya cook and if so you can
either icook or some sort of an ethical
review board on site that looks at
or that periodically reviews the
activities on site and so if they do ask
to see the minutes
and just
be nice to have information
documentations of quality control so
product quality control either they're
animals colony health monitoring reports
you can ask to see test results for the
water for their diet
etc
and i always ask to see their emergency
and disaster preparedness
plan okay
you know you want to know if something
were to happen you know either
it's due to
natural disaster
um or you know due to equipment failure
if something were to happen that
interrupts their production how is the
shortage of supply going to impact your
operation so you want to see that the
vendors that you work with actually has
a plan in place
okay
and on the day of the visit generally
what happens is that you show up after
some small talk chit chat
um your host will give you a
quick overview of the company uh history
of the business uh it'll talk about you
know facility operation
um and then a brief overview of their
available products and services and
sometimes they'll even talk about future
directions of the company
and before
afterwards before everybody gets up and
and go on the tour
be sure to provide your host with that
list of
uh
of documents you wish to review so that
while you're out there walking around
and talking to people they have folks
you know collecting this information for
you
um
and of course during the time you spend
uh performing
your your walkthroughs touring the
facility you know bring something to
write with you so that when you
see something that's worth noteworthy
you know whether something good or
something
you know that alarms you you know be
sure to jot it down and try to be
specific
and and after return from the tour you
want to review all the documents that
requested um plus a little bit more
and you know talk to your host talk to
you know key personnel there
and and during this process while you're
reviewing the documents it's also a good
way for you to assess the vendor's
record-keeping system okay whether or
not they're organized do they have an
archiving system
um
and then at the end before you leave as
as common courtesy you want to
have an exit briefing and just disclose
some of the things that you've seen you
know whether they be good they'd be bad
um provide your hosts with your comments
and feedback you know again this is to
help build that partnership between
the two institutions
and at the end of the audit the goal is
that
you want to find out whether or not this
vendor's product or their services
is able to meet your standards okay
everybody has their own internal center
that they set okay and also their needs
so whether or not they meet your
expectations and may not
you know
everybody is different so that that
needs to be established
um and also you want to help
the vendor improve themselves you know
look at things that
uh potentially not only will benefit you
but all of their other customers as well
so make those suggestions um because
ultimately you know we we have the
responsibility to to push and drive this
process and drive for to to raise the
bar
um
of the quality
of the the product and services used in
biomedical research so
um and
and i think of it at the end um you know
the quality of a product really is
um proportional i guess is dependent on
the actual effort put into the
production of that product right and so
if you have a so-so standard then
probably at the end it's going to
reflect in your research data it's going
to be uh so-so all right
okay
so
moving on to animal production
um i
like to simplify that and for the lay
people out there you know the general
flow of things production is such okay
you have a breeding colony you know
animals have to come from somewhere so
breeding population
and this population has to have
a regular monitoring of their health
profile their pedigree information is
probably tracked
their production performance should be
tracked and there are some
measures in place to prevent
cross-contamination whether it be
against microbial cause contamination or
from genetic cross-contamination
okay
and all those animals once they're born
they go into a stock population and
these are the population that then gets
sold to the customers okay
and then in this population you want to
pay attention to the rearing environment
you know the staff that are working with
them
um you want to pay attention to the
model phenotype
and also the availability of these
models
okay and before the animals go out the
door there is generally a quality
control component associated okay
there's genetic monitoring hopefully
there's health monitoring
if there are sick animals or abnormal
animals veterinary care is provided
and all of this operation of course
is carried out following sets of
standard operating procedures okay
and then as they go out the door there's
you know you want to consider the
shipping
to transportation so the containers
itself whether or not is suitable for
the species
the transportation vehicle is it climate
controlled um is it
properly cleaned out before and after
shipments you know some of the biosafety
measures that helps protect the products
but also protects
this this vendors customers
okay
so
moving right along um i think when you
show up at an animal vendors facility
you know i think first impression can be
very important
um think about
you know how you would feel if you were
to show up and the vendor says i'm sorry
but you can't come in okay
so that lack of transparency i think
then says something about their
operation or the products
okay
um or if you show up at a facility and
it's very disorganized um it's dirty
then that probably will be reflected in
the quality of their animals as well
okay
look at the physical maintenance of the
facility um their equipment their rooms
their um overall architecture their
structural components
and as you look don't just look straight
ahead you know remember to look up and
look down as well
you know look at the ceilings the light
fixtures you know corners of the room
are there cobwebs all over the place on
the floor there are cracks that
potentially allows insects to come in
you know and the overall
maintenance of that facility i think
you can see
how much the vendor invests in their
operation by looking at the overall
structure itself i think
um go check out the breeders uh the
different populations how they're held
you know
you could very well end up in in in a
room and you see you know
a room full of ibc cages and certainly
if you have those ivc cages look to see
how they're handling the animals outside
of ibc cages and hopefully there is a
um you know some sort of a biological
safety cabinet or some sort of a cling
bench used to protect a product inside
um or it could be inside a barrier room
and you just have open top cages of
animals
um or animals may be reared in isolators
and so you know check out how these
different husbandry or housing systems
uh impacts the animals and whether or
not they make sense for the health
status of the animals you're trying to
purchase
okay
so
look at their husbandry sanitation
practice um i talked about caging their
feed water bedding how do they prepare
it um and so on and so forth ask for
those questions and as you walk
uh generally if you can ask the staff
that are working there you know ask them
the questions about what their daily
work is like you know ask them to
describe for you and then remember those
key points and then later on when you go
and review the sops you can then cross
reference and see if what they say they
do actually is what the sop says for
them to do okay
um look at how they monitor the health
of their animals their colonies
how often do they do it what do they
test for
how many what is the sample size they
test for you know are there historic
data available
um
reports of abnormal clinical signs
are the vendors are the technicians or
the staff working in the room are they
conscientious about
these clinical signs and then
identifying them early so that you can
start weeding out
those breeders perhaps that are
prone to
producing animals with these
abnormalities and thereby decreasing the
incidence of clinical signs in the whole
colony
ask about surgery areas do they have one
you know if they perform surgically
modification of animal models and
selling them as a product then ask to
see that area you know how are animals
are right over there and then how do
they leave ask about their
anesthesia analgesia protocols ask about
euthanasia how do they do it
and ask about waste disposal and this is
not only soil bedding you know
waste water but also carcasses animal
carcasses where do they go
um
ask about the transportation you know do
they have their own vehicles or do they
contract out the service to third party
to to deliver
their products
um for large animals
some of the key
areas that you want to
focus on will apply
and i just want to point out some of the
differences
one is that for large animal species a
lot of the vendors will have this
outdoor component to their their
facility okay
and if it does have this outdoor
component meaning you know it's exposure
to to nature it's great but you also
think about
all the
possibilities of disease transmission
you know that's result of
wild animals uh wild insects and well
they are all wild so wild animals and
insects that potentially serve as
vectors for transmitting diseases
and if there is that potential then you
want to ask whether or not the vendors
actually screen for them do they care
again look at the physical maintenance
of the facility uh
the the overall conditions you know are
there
is it full of rust and sharp edges that
animals could potentially hurt
themselves on
um
the
the pen configuration does it allow
admirals to to easily exercise and
interact with each other
um ask to see the breeding scheme you
know um do they have systems in place to
to
prevent
you know inbreeding of certain lines
um how do they select their breeders
when do they choose to retire them
um what kind of enrichment
do they provide for their animals you
know
ask
as far as veterinary care goes you want
to ask to see areas where they perform
quarantine they may or they may not have
that uh quarantine you want to ask about
vaccination schedule you know do they do
that because sometimes
you may not want several positive
animals for your studies
so whether or not they perform
vaccinations on their animals what is
the schedule what product do they use
where do they get that from
are there any prophylactic treatments
that you give
some vendors will mix medication right
into the feed and then they give it to
their animals which then would be
bad for your research because they're
suppressing clinical signs that you
should be catching and then it's also
going to produce false negative results
and the last thing you want is to bring
in animals that look healthy um and then
after some time they start coming down
with diseases and and you have to treat
them
okay so find out
um go and ask to see their veterinary
treatment labs you know where do they
keep their drugs what does their
pharmacy look like you know is it a
a
clean environments you know
sterile or does it look like a butcher
shop
surgery areas definitely take a look at
that on whether or not the environment
is conducive to aseptic surgical
technique you know what type of
surgeries did they perform
um diagnostic labs you know
when they monitored the health uh
profiles of their the animals in their
colony
do they do this in-house or do they
submit the samples out to to a third
party contractor
and you know
every step along the way asked to see
the records you know
um
look for the raw data and not just
what they provide for you
okay
now switching gear a little bit moving
to animal diet i just want to mention
that um you know food safety of course
is on everybody's mind it's very
important and for research animals
the
the the diet really is really
a principle source of foreign compound
exposure for these animals we're talking
about you know
within these diets there are natural and
synthetic chemical compounds
uh potentially there may be contaminants
that are found
either naturally on plant material or
as as a pesticide residue from
agricultural products
um
these diets may become contaminated
during the storage process or during the
the diet formulation production process
um and
you know there could be variations in
the nutritional content you know with
each of these ingredients um and
sometimes
that that variation in nutritional
contact can can impact your animal
health and the animal phenotype
and
or worse you know they have been
implicated in
um i guess outbreaks in certain
facilities and so
um this picture here is really just as
an example to show
your it is possible to see this clinical
sign which is hydrocephaly in rabid kids
um and that could result from either you
know vitamin a toxicity or vitamin a
deficiency in a diet so
oh
does the vendor check all of
that so again um just quickly general
flow of animal diet production from a
layman's term
think about
think think think about
the process you know starting from the
raw ingredients so the raw material your
main ingredients your micronutrients
these are the vitamins and the minerals
the storage conditions that they're held
in and then hopefully there's some type
of quality control that takes place
before they are used to produce animal
diets
and while in production
they are brought to an environment and
that is hopefully hygienic
and
everything goes into a giant mixture
they get mixed following a formula for a
specific diet and using different types
of equipment and then at the end spits
out you know either
pellets or extruded diets or
meals
and they're packaged and
onto to the next step in the production
chain
there are control points set up at
different
uh
different points of the production to
assess the quality and and reject
products that do not meet the standards
and
and at the end after
uh passing all the the scrutiny then the
product gets
sent to
another location and ready to be
distributed so storage condition and
then they're delivered to the consumers
themselves okay
and so
when you
i don't know how many people actually
have seen how diets are made
um but don't
you know how animal diets are made is
very different from how
uh i guess human human food is made so
the environment is going to be different
the the sanitation level i should let's
just say
um so when you show up again
look at the facility's overall condition
and environment you know is it a giant
warehouse or a giant barn with open
doors and raw ingredients in bags that
just sits on the floor and it's open
and you know any wild critter you know
birds rodents can just come in and have
a feast essentially or is it all
contained in a nicely
uh you know nice and secure warehouse
where you require badge access to enter
you want to look around for evidence of
pest control because like i said these
raw ingredients are perfect uh
nutritionally to to
keep a lot of wild insects and
wildlife
alive for a while
um
you want to ask about the source of the
raw ingredients so some of these corn
wheats um you know these grains where do
they come from you know does the vendor
the producers do they even check okay
um look at again the storage conditions
of these components and then ask whether
or not the vendor actually produces
species specific diets um because as far
as i know you know you don't have just
one vendor producing one type of diet
now most likely they're gonna generate a
whole lot of different products and so
you want to ask about
whether or not there's a
cross-contamination control in place
um look at the type of equipment that
they use you know do they have an
automated system that uses basically
computer generated you know um i guess
computer operated
computer controlled equipment that mix
various ingredients together
automatically or do you have people
walking around with little scoops you
know measuring things out and
and
formulating the diet
which is
fine i guess for for some folks that may
be okay
but you want to go a step further and
just check to see if they have
regular maintenance records on these
scales that they use you know these
balances to ensure that whatever it is
that they're measuring is actually what
this should be
because you know for our research
consistency of the product is very very
important so consistency in not only the
ingredients but also the nutritional
values of it
so
um and the vendors themselves hopefully
will
check their products at different time
points
and just be sure to ask about that
because like i said again everybody is
different
um and as products are produced what
does the product packaging look like you
know does it make sense does it protect
the product inside you know
the labeling that goes on the outside
does it make sense
and as i mentioned before for different
types of diets how do they prevent
cross-contamination you know especially
if the vendor potentially will
produce medicated feed you know some
sort of a diet to treat agricultural
farm animals
how can you ensure that some of this
medication don't end up accidentally in
your diet that you feed to your research
animals
so i want to ask about that
um look at where they store their
finished product you know if it's like a
high-fat diet most likely they're going
to require some type of cold storage to
prevent the product from spoiling
um do they have some type of inventory
control to make sure that they send out
products and they don't just sit around
so that when you do order the products
you receive something that will expire
in one to two months so then that's
really not
useful for you
so some type of inventory control and
tracking system
um
what is their criteria for product
testing and release okay so what is the
standard
and ask them about you know what happens
when a batch of tests a batch of diet
does not pass inspection or it expires
what do they do with that you know
everyone everyone will say yes they
destroy it but you just want to make
sure that um
you know there are
you're not working with these
vendors questionable practice where they
potentially you know
repackage that product for for
other purposes
okay
um and of course think about what
happens if the plant operation isn't
interrupted okay because
if they are your only vendor and they
stop producing the diet that you need
you're screwed so
um how does a vendor
protect themselves or protect you you
know
so ask about their plans
um for betting vendors um i guess either
you're working with wood shaving wood
products or you're working with corn
cobs or
paper products
you know just out of curiosity go and
see
um where these material these products
are made okay
um is it just
you know off of some guy's garage
somewhere with a wood chipper and the
guy's adding wood and where does that
wood come from what kind of wood is it
you know hopefully not
treated lumber that they use in
construction because those will have
some sort of a chemical in it that may
or may not be useful or
helpful
helpful for your study
um if you use diagnostic laboratories
for
testing you know go and
see what their labs look like you know
is it clean orderly
what kind of equipment do they use if
they use test kits you know
what are those
um look at how they process sample from
one area to another
and how do they prevent
cross-contamination from occurring okay
and the reporting timeline okay how long
does it take for you to from the time of
sample submission to the time you get a
report and whether or not the
the the lab has
um
i guess whether or not they confirm
positive findings for you you know
through other assays or do they just
here give you the test results and that
does not provide you with any additional
assistance technical assistance
um
so then after your tour after you jot
down some of the area
things that you want to follow up on
uh go back to the conference room sit
down and review that checklist and make
sure you are
going through all the relevant points
that you you want to look at before you
make your final assessment
again review the sops for things that
you identified
based on your discussion with the staff
you know whether or not
what they say they do
follows the sop and also look at their
records okay match their records to the
sop to see if they
um
if it makes sense
um and of course again ask to see the
raw data and not computer generated a
spit out sheet
um what else
and as you speak with these
key responsible personnel you know the
attending vets the operation managers
tech support you know on the side you're
really assessing their technical
expertise right and you're seeing
whether or not these people that you
want to partner up with whether or not
they can provide you with scientific and
technical support when something does
happen you know when you need help are
they there or do they just sell you a
product and they say you know you're on
your own
and post visit really it's similar to an
i could semi annual inspection i think
um
for everything that you identify that
may be a suggestion for improvement or
maybe deficiencies you know ask for
vendor to provide you with a response
okay but be aware that
you know the vendors don't necessarily
have to do anything you say okay they
can go on to
going back to their regular operation
they don't have to
take your suggestions into consideration
okay we would like that they do because
through that method is how we all
improve
right
but
um so with your list generate your
report document your findings and
observations try to be as specific as
possible and give examples
and
be courteous and provide your host with
this list okay and if you're asking for
a response you know set a deadline for
follow-up
to to follow up on
and based on the response that you get
back it may be necessary for you to go
back to the vendor and perform
additional uh visits before you can
qualify them to
to use uh in your institution
okay
and as you
i guess continue to use these products
and services in in within your vivarium
in your
institution
um
continue to assess the product quality
received right
you want to check the animals after they
arrive you know look at the paperwork
does it make sense um the animal's
condition you know do they look healthy
or are they dehydrated you know are you
seeing mix-ups of males and females
being lumped together okay that would be
a big mistake are you seeing lesions
from animals that may have been
sustained you know these trauma may have
been sustained during the transport
process and if so then look at the
transport carriers is it bad or is it
some other problem
okay and over time as you use these
models on studies they'll pay attention
to any changes in their model
performance you know
um because
that could see that could be um that
could signify a shift in your vendor's
breeding practice
um
um and of course product quality you
constantly want to assess and you know
things like you open up a dog a bag of
dog food and you find straw and you know
that should not be there so that should
raise the red flag for you and anytime
you identify these issues these problems
you want to be sure to communicate with
the vendors in a timely manner okay
and if you can take photographs and
document that okay send it off
okay and at the end i just want to
stress again we're trying to build a
relationship a partnership right
and as a animal user as a customer i
think it is fair to expect these
following
uh key things from our our vendors right
we expect them to be knowledgeable about
the products that they sell and to be
able to provide us with technical
support when we do have questions okay
we
expect them to share the same commitment
and passion towards responsible research
otherwise
you know
they they're not the right people to to
be matched up with
um we expect them to be willing to make
appropriate changes to meet our
expectations because it will it will not
only benefit
you as a customer but also all of their
other customers as well
and we expect them to be proactive
because if something were to go
wrong on their end we expect them to
proactively notify us and give us
advanced warning whether it be
identification of a specific pathogen in
their breeding colony
or equipment failure and shutdown
something like that okay
um there's just very quickly some
etiquettes a bit about do's and don'ts
um
when you're performing
vendor audits um visiting vendors um do
be punctual you know be on time so that
you can start on time and end on time
okay be courteous in that way dress
professionally you know and and be
careful about how you conduct yourself
you know if you're kind of like mama
huhu then um you know people won't take
you seriously
um certainly as you visit different
places be open-minded and be aware that
there are more than one way to
accomplish a goal okay so be open-minded
listen to what they say you know
consider the options and really consider
the performance standard okay look at
your end product and whether or not that
works okay
don't go to a vendor and purposely try
to find fault or blame okay because
that really will antagonize them it's
not a good foundation for building a
relationship
try not to discuss any comfort uh
company confidential information such as
your client base uh your studies your
budget things like that
okay because those are company
confidential
um and certainly you don't want to be
giving them competitor information so
for example if you're visiting
one vendor after another don't tell the
second vendor what you learned in the
first vendor about their operation and
whether they're good or they're bad
things like that so
um and at the end you know just really
think about
why you you you want to do this you know
it's important because it is part of
um
your animal care and use program okay
and your veterinary care program and how
you manage that
your operation depends on the quality of
the things that you use
right that makes sense
and then ultimately you know are you
confident
allowing these animals and these
products into your facility you know are
you confident that they are going to
allow your scientists to produce um
consistent data
you know do you trust the data that is
produced and you know do you trust that
the vendors are transparent and they're
honest with you
so
that's pretty much the key point and if
you do have that trust then i think you
know this working relationship can be
um
can can go on a long time
all right
so
that is all i have this morning or this
evening and with the remaining time if
there are any questions i will try to
answer them
and i am not seeing any questions at
this point and so
uh for those of you
i guess joining us through
by
through recordings only if you have
questions or comments feel free to email
me my email address is
listed here
on the slide
all right
thank you everyone happy new year again